NEW PROGRESSIVE, THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
NOW, THREE WEEKS AGO, WE SHOWED
YOU HOW THE DEMOCRAT
INFOTAINMENT COMPLEX, BETO
O'ROURKE WITH A GLOSSY,
BEAUTIFUL VANITY FAIR FEATURE.
THE FORMER TEXAN CONGRESSMAN A
PEN UP WITH IMPRESSIVE
FUND-RAISING HOLE.
HE WENT FROM TEXAS SENATE RATE
LOSER TO MODERN-DAY MATINEE IDOL
COMPLETELY ADORING FEMALE FANS,
BUT STILL IT SEEMED LIKE, MAY BE
JUST FLAILING, BUT THEN CAME A
PART-TIME PARENT IN HIS APOLOGY
FOR HIS PRIVILEGE AND DIDN'T YOU
JUST START FEELING EXHAUSTED BY
IT ALL?
I THINK IN THIS WEIRD, NEW CYCLE
BAIT OH ALREADY SEEMS LIKE
YESTERDAY'S NEWS.
MEANWHILE, THE NEWEST DARLING OF
JOURNALIST, HOLLYWOOD'S AND
METRO LEFTIES IS A MAYOR OF
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
MEET 37-YEAR-OLD PETE, NAVY
RESERVIST, HER BIG RED, ROAD
SCHOLAR AND A MARRIED MAN IF HE
WON THE PRESIDENCY WOULD BE A
PRESIDENTIAL FIRST.
AND REMEMBER AMERICA LIKES
FIRST, THE COASTAL ELITE, I
DON'T THINK THEY'VE EVER LOVED A
MIDWESTERNER AS MUCH AS THEY
LOVE PETE.
HE IS A CHARMER.
HE IS DISARMINGLY CHARMING AND
HE HAS LIKE AN INNOCENCE ABOUT
HIM BUT AT THE SAME TIME, HE IS
AN INTELLECTUAL.
>> Laura: OH, ANNA, HE'S
BEYOND INTELLECTUAL.
>> I GUESS THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
ACTUALLY BE INSIGHTFUL,
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THE ISSUES
AND ALSO HAVING A GO POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE COUNTS FOR SOMETHING
IN POLITICS.
HE'S FIRST ON POLICY AND CAN
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING YOU ASK HIM.
>> Laura: HE SO DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
>> INCREDIBLE TO SEE HOW HE'S
BEEN ABLE TO RISE, BEING THE
COMPLETE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE SEE
RIGHT NOW IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE WAY HE
SPEAKS, JUST AS CALMNESS, HIS
CHARACTER.
HE DOESN'T LIKE WOMEN.
>> Laura: AND, YES, HE'S
HUMBLE.
>> I WENT TO HER REFERRED IN THE
U.K. TO STUDY AFTER THAT.
AND THAT'S WHEN I REALIZED, IT
IT DIDN'T MATTER TO ME.
>> BUT YOU WERE A SCHOLAR.
A VERY HUMBLE GUY.
>> Laura: LEFT THIS AND NEVER
TRUMP BEST ACROSS THE LAND ARE
FALLING IN LOVE.
>> WE JUST GOT INUNDATED WITH
CALLS BY PEOPLE SAYING, THIS GUY
IS THE REAL THING.
WE LOVE MAY REPEAT.
>> Laura: PRONOUNCING HIS LAST
NAME, THAT IS AN ISSUE
ALTOGETHER.
PETE BUTTIGIEG, WE SAW PETER
BUTTIGIEG OF MINNEAPOLIS.
>> THERE WAS SOMETHING IN THE
MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT EASY, OKAY?
I THINK I MADE IT THROUGH THE
MONOLOGUE WITHOUT SLASHING IT
ONCE.
BUT DON'T BET ON ME.
PETE MAKES LIGHT OF HIS LAST
NAME.
CHECK OUT THE WALL OF HIS NEW
OFFICE.
>> WE ARE FINDING OUR WAY INTO
THIS NEW HEADQUARTERS WHICH IS
FULL OF INCREASINGLY FANTASTIC
TEAM.
THERE IS NOTHING ANYBODY ELSE
WILL KNOW HOW TO SAY THE NAME.
>> Laura: FET IS CUTE
DOOGIE HOWSER KIND OF FIGURE
KIND OF WAY.
BUT WHAT DO WE REALLY KNOW ABOUT
THE NEW "IT BOY"?
HE SPENT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
AFFORDED A LOT OF LOCALS OF
HORROR.
AND SEEMS TO HAVE TROUBLE
KEEPING TRACK OF THE HOMICIDE
NUMBERS IN HIS CITY.
>> WHEN I WAS A KID, IT WAS NOT
UNUSUAL TO HAVE 20 HOMICIDES IN
SOUTH BEND.
LAST YEAR WE HAD NINE.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY TOO MANY.
>> LOOK AS YOUR TERM AS MAYOR
AND IT'S GONNA.
>> I WOULD CHOOSE UP-AND-DOWN
YEAR TO YEAR IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HOMICIDE RATE.
>> Laura: LOOK, BUTTIGIEG IS
REALLY SMART AND WORKED AT THE
GLOBAL CONSULTANT COMPANY AND
AFTER FINISHING AT OXFORD.
HE SAYS HE'S A TRADITIONAL
EPISCOPALIAN WHATEVER THAT MEANS
THESE DAYS IN A "NEW YORK TIMES"
COLUMN, NEOCON MORALIST DAVID
BROKE IN FULL FAN BOY MODE,
RIGHT, THE JUDGE IS AND
PERSONIFIED BY THE LGBTQ
MOVEMENT BUT IT DOESN'T DO SO
IN A WAY THAT FEELS THREATENING
OR TRANSGRESSIVE TO SOCIAL
CONSERVATIVES.
HE HAS CONSERVATIVE FAMILY
VALUES.
AND IT'S JUST HIS SPOUSE HAS A
HUSBAND, NOT A WIFE.
FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY SOCIAL CONSERVATIVES DAVID
BROOKS ACTUALLY KNOWS OR
INTERVIEWED FOR THE COLUMN, BUT
SUPPORT FOR ABORTION ON DEMAND
DOES NOT QUALIFY.
AS THEY DID WITH THE OBAMA THE
MEDIA IS ATTEMPTING TO TAKE AN
OFFICE WITH LIMITED EXPERIENCE
AND WRAP HIM UP IN A WARM, FUZZY
PERSONAL, NARRATIVE.
>> Laura: SOUTH BEND, INDIANA,
NUTLEY THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
PRESIDENTIAL.
MIRRORING LAST YEAR.
>> A MARRIED A TEACHER SO I
MARRIED.
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED TO GET TO
KNOW HIM ON A MUCH LARGER SCALE.
>> Laura: ALSO WITH OBAMA, HIS
PARENTS WERE RADICAL, HIS FATHER
WHOM HE DESCRIBES IN HIS MEMOIR
AS THE MAN ON THE LEFT WAS A
NOTRE DAME LITERATURE PROFESSOR
SO THAT IS GREAT BUT ACCORDING
TO THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
TO THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER,"
BUTTIGIEG A COMMITTED MARS COULD
ASSIST WITH THE MANIFESTO AND
WORKED TO INJECT MERCE --
MARXISM INTO THE WIDER CULTURE.
PETE WAS CLOSE TO HIS FATHER
WHICH YOU CAN EXPECT WHICH WILL
EAT OF COURSE MANY VOTERS TO
WONDER HOW FAR ARE THE APPLE
FELL FROM THE TREE, BUT THE
QUESTION WILL BE ASKED ON
CAMPAIGN TRAIL BUT COME ON, WHY
FIXATE ON ANY OF THAT QUESTION
DOES IT MATTER?
DAVID BROOKS SAYS HE IS A WASH
IN A CONSERVATIVE FAMILY VALUES.
DESPITE NEVER HELD STATEWIDE
OFFICE, BUTTIGIEG HAS SOMETHING
ELSE GOING FOR HIM "HE'S A
PROGRESSIVE ON POLICY ISSUES,
BUT HE DOESN'T SOUND LIKE AN
ANGRY REVOLUTIONARY."
HE CHOOSES GRAND IDEOLOGICAL
CONFLICT.
THIS READS LIKE AN OLD OBAMA
ROAD.
DID HE WRITE THE SAME THING
ABOUT OBAMA?
THE AURA AND THE HISTORIC NATURE
OF THE MAN IS FAR MORE IMPORTANT
THAN THE SUBSTANCE KIDS, GET
USED TO IT.
BUT IGNORE THE GAUZY PROFILE AND
YOU FIND BUTTIGIEG'S PRETTY MUCH
A GARDEN-VARIETY LEFTIST.
KIND OF CALM AND SOFT SPOKEN FOR
SURE.
BUT HE SUPPORTS THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, A WEALTH TAX, SINGLE PAYER
HEALTH PLAN, AMNESTY, FOR
CERTAIN ILLEGALS AND PACKING THE
COURT WITH MORE THAN NINE
JUSTICES AND THEN THERE IS THIS.
>> THE JUSTICE COURT GETTING RID
OF ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
ABSOLUTELY, IT'S GOT TO GO.
>> Laura: DON'T BE FOOLED BY
CURATED DAMAGE.
THE GUY BELIEVES IN A SET OF
POLICIES THAT WOULD SET BACK THE
ECONOMIC GAIN AND TAKE MONEY OUT
OF THE POCKETS OF PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS
THAT DON'T.
HE WAS UP IN THE CONSTITUTION TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK TRUMP THE VIEWS OF
HEARTLAND EVERY TIME.
AND LAST AUGUST HE SAID
PRESIDENT TRUMP A DISGRACED GAME
SHOW HOST.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, HE SAID
THIS A SOCIALIST EXTREMIST THE
LIKES OF WHICH OUR COUNTRY HAS
NOT KNOWN.
IN IN NATIONAL POLITICS.
WOW SO MUCH FOR CONSERVATIVE
FAMILY VALUES.
AND BEYOND BOY SCOUT DEMEANOR
AND MAYOR BUTTIGIEG IS A CREATOR
OF MEDIA APPARATUS DESPERATE TO
OUST TRUMP.
THE SAME REASON THEY BUILT UP
AOC AND BETO TO WHIP UP THE
DEMOCRAT BASE, KEEP THEM EXCITED
TO, KEEP THEM ENGAGED.
ANYTHING TO DIVERT VOTERS
ATTENTION FROM THE GROWING
401(K), BIGGER PAYCHECK AND ALL
THAT GOOD NEWS THAT HAPPEN
BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S POLICIES.